[Music]
in february congress grilled executives
from robin hood and citadel securities
over their role in the gamestop trading
frenzy
and throughout the hearing a phrase came
up over and over again
payment per order flow payment for order
flow payment for overflow payment for
order flow
with respect to payment for order flow
we simply
play by the rules the road payment for
order flow is a decade's old practice
that's at the heart of how commission
free brokers
operate and it's creating controversy
critics claim that the practice creates
a conflict of interest
that is bad for investors while it may
enable free commissions and explicit
costs
there are implied costs we feel everyone
ignores
but supporters say the practice is
misunderstood and that it's actually
good for investors whether you're a
robin hood client or a fidelity client
you're getting a price that is at or
better than the national best bit of
best offer
right that's the thing there's nothing
nefarious going on here following the
gamestop episode
the sec is expected to conduct a review
that could change the rules of payment
for order flow
and how brokers operate
[Music]
when an investor buys a stock on a
commission free trading app the
transaction is executed
almost instantly but a lot is going on
behind the scenes
let's take a look at the main players
there are buyers the investors who want
to purchase a stock
and there are sellers the investors who
want to unload a stock
there's also the broker the firm that
accepts investors orders and makes sure
they get executed
and finally there are the market makers
which buy the orders from the broker and
execute them these are usually high
frequency traders like virtue financial
and citadel securities and they are the
players that make the trade actually
happen
when you're the investor and you're
buying the market maker's selling
if you're the investor and you're
selling the market maker is buying
but the market maker hopes to do a lot
of little trades all day long
and eventually arrive at a place where
they're flat
zero commission brokers make money by
selling customers orders to market
makers
this is payment for order flow the
practice enables trades to be executed
at a high volume
very quickly it also means that most
orders entered by small investors never
get sent to public exchanges
like the new york stock exchange or
nasdaq instead small investors orders
get executed privately by market makers
let's break down how the process works
say an investor wants to sell 200 shares
of a stock
so they place an order with a broker the
chances that another person wants to buy
that exact amount of shares at the same
time
is pretty low but that's okay because
the broker
routes the orders to a market maker the
market maker fills it within a fraction
of a second
but that comes with risk the risk that
the price of the stock could fall before
the market maker can sell the 200 shares
to someone else
the market maker is paid for taking on
this risk through what is known as the
bid ask spread
you can see it here the spread is the
difference in price between what buyers
are paying for a stock
and what sellers are selling for it
doesn't usually amount to much
on stock exchanges it's often just a
penny per share
when market makers execute trades
privately the spread can be
even tighter this is because the prices
can be in fractions of a penny
say using our example that the spread is
just half a cent
so buying and selling those 200 shares
would make the market maker
one dollar but as millions of shares are
traded the profits from the spread add
up
it's easy money for them the retail
investors are small they don't place
very large orders and they don't tend to
be
extremely well informed about the
movements of the stock price
in 2020 these brokerages collected
almost 2.6 billion dollars in payments
for stock and option orders
and this is part of what's driving the
current controversy over the practice
some critics say that payment for order
flow creates a conflict of interest
between the broker's duty to seek the
best execution for trades
and its desire to maximize its own
profits
in the u.s brokers have what is called a
duty of best execution
they have to get you the best possible
execution on your trades or at least
attempt to do so if a broker is taking a
lot of money and payment for order
overflow
then odds are it's not really giving you
a best execution
critics say this is because brokerages
could be tempted to send customer orders
to the market centers
that pay them the biggest rebate or that
brokers could be demanding greater
payments from the market makers
this is why the practice is banned in
some other countries like the uk
in other countries where payment for
flow is illegal
everything has to go to exchanges so
everything is in the
lit markets where everybody can see the
price is coming together
all the trading happens kind of out in
the open
some critics even worry that market
makers could be front-running investor
stock trades
but supporters say these claims aren't
true brokers and market makers argue
that payment for order flow often gives
investors a better price than the best
market price
and that it helps make trading easier so
payment forward flow has a very big
benefit for investors
and that is it has allowed the emergence
of zero commission trading
it was just a few years ago that brokers
were typically charging
495 795 or more for a single stock trade
a couple years ago that went away robin
hood set the practice
and then a bunch of others like schwab
td ameritrade
e-trade followed a robin hood
spokesperson said that robin hood sends
customer orders to market makers that
typically offer better prices than
public exchanges and that it's proud of
what it's done to change the industry
for all retail investors
in the past the sec has approved of
payment for order flow as long as
brokers make certain disclosures
like where they're routing investors
orders and how much they're getting paid
for them
the agency has said that small investors
generally get better prices when their
orders are sent to market makers
rather than exchanges but the volatility
in gamestop is raising alarms in
congress where lawmakers are calling for
fresh scrutiny of payment for order flow
in february sec acting chairwoman alison
herron lee wrote a letter showing
support for a wholesale review of the
practice
if the review uncovers any sort of
abuses what i think is most likely going
to happen is that the sec
will require some sort of new
disclosures coming out of brokers
and maybe out of market makers if
payment forward flow were banned
market makers would still be able to
make money after all
they're still doing the same thing
collecting the bid ask spread
however the thing that would likely
change is that zero commission trading
would be endangered as the gamestop saga
continues to unfold
the future of payment for order flow and
zero commission trading
remains uncertain